how can millennials create better
relationships with gen z
uh uh and try to impart on them that
technology is not the end-all be-all ah
the irony is thick i love it
um
um one is to put them in situations if
possible um
where they feel what it feels like to
have genuine connection i had a
um let's call it debate
with a sixteen-year-old recently um
where i
maybe complained that her generation
doesn't know how to have conversations
and she pushed back very hard and said
yes we do
we have conversations all the time i
said you rely on your cell phones and
social media to talk to each other she
goes no we don't i send voice my most to
friends and i wait and i sort of had to
pause me i'm like wait a minute you send
a voice memo to someone they send the
voice memo back to you you send a voice
memo back to them they send a voice
member back to you and you think this is
a conversation and she said yes because
how do we define conversation we're
talking with each other so they think
that talking
like making recordings and listening to
them in real time is a conversation
i find it to be very avoidant right um
where a you can't read body language you
can't the tone of voice is missed you
can't interrupt great conversations are
interruptive you know
it's not one than the other then one
then the other that's like a formal
debate um conversations are messy like
people are messy and that's what makes
them fun
um it's not talking at people it's
talking with people um and so i think
the the best thing we can do is just
keep doing the things that we think are
important um the good news is gen z are
younger uh so we can put them in
situations you know we can make them
take their phones away we can go out for
dinner with them and ask them to put
their phones away or take you know i do
this with my friends where we all trade
phones when we go out for dinner so when
you go to the bathroom you don't have
your phone you have somebody else's um
and you just have to like and like when
you're the one waiting you know uh you
can't check your phone you have to sort
of enjoy the surroundings but the point
is is is try find opportunities where
you can put each other well you can put
them in situations where they can enjoy
good old-fashioned human contact talking
and let them experience the difference
and talk to them about their friends um
this is one thing that i've had great
success with where i don't talk about
them and what's wrong with them and i
don't complain about them i ask them
about their friends do your friends feel
this do your friends struggle tell me
about how your friends deal with
stress and a lot more honesty comes out
about their friends and i say how are
you helping your friends and then i i
talk about how being present for your
friends matters and they start to
realize that putting their phone away is
an act of service so don't make it about
them make it about their friends and how
they're taking care of their friends and
you're much more likely to connect and
get through them